foreign
nothing quite captures that you only
live once mentality of investors during
the early days of the pandemic as spax
short for special purpose acquisition
companies these blank check companies
emerge from the backwaters of Finance to
become one of the most in-demand asset
classes on Wall Street
they plug in celebrities well known
financiers and Retail investors raised
hundreds of billions of dollars in cash
and struck Mega deals at an
unprecedented Pace but the spat craze
has almost certainly come to an end
bruised by the terrible performance of
companies that went public through these
vehicles angry investors have abandoned
the market and a tough regulatory
environment how it all happened will be
a story for the ages
companies that were valued at tens of
billions of dollars are today worth just
a fraction of that amount and some have
even filed for bankruptcy
spax raised almost 100 billion dollars
in the first quarter of 2021 alone but
when Regulators set their sights on the
nascent Market the impact was felt
quickly spark listings dropped
dramatically and deals that were once
certain to close started to look shaky
few investors wanted to provide
financing and when time came to close a
transaction most shareholders asked
their money back leaving companies that
opted to this back route with very
little cash in their coffers to make
matters worse banks that spent the past
two years moving sponsors and companies
are backing off after making hundreds of
millions of dollars in fees in a final
blow to the market hedge fund
billionaire Bill Ackman was forced to
liquidate his record-breaking 4 billion
dollars back just weeks before a
two-year deadline to find a deal
approached his bank check company was
widely expected to strike the biggest
fact transaction ever instead
shareholders are getting their money
back a similar fate is expected for most
facts still looking to find Targets most
experts now expect blank check companies
to go back to where they were prior to
the 2020 Boom the dark corners of
financial markets
[Music]